ya sabemos calcular el área de un
triángulo equilátero lo que vamos a
hacer en este vídeo es hallar el área de
lo que y no sé si lo pronuncia bien pero
lo voy a decir cómo se lee de lo que es
el copo de nieve de coche éste se
construye poniendo un triángulo
equilátero y cada uno de sus lados los
partimos en tres segmentos iguales de
cada uno de esos segmentos trazamos un
nuevo triángulo equilátero y esto lo
hacemos una vez más con cada uno de los
lados yo creo que ya tienes la idea
general de cómo se resuelve o más bien
cómo se construye lo que vamos a hacer
es demostrar que tiene un área finita a
pesar de que en vídeos anteriores ya
vimos que tiene un perímetro infinito lo
cual es bastante interesante si si te
pones a pensarlo así que iniciamos con
un triángulo equilátero vamos a suponer
que tiene una medida s una medida de s y
como es equilátero éste tiene todos sus
lados de igual medida y que suponemos
que es ese
vamos a guardar registro de cuántos
lados vamos construyendo a lo largo de
los pasos de de construir el copo de
nieve ok y también vamos a hacer cuenta
de cuánta área vamos sumando déjenme
borrar todo esto porque al parecer creo
que vamos a necesitar mucho espacio así
que guardamos registro de los lados del
número de lados y del área que vamos
sumando ok así que vamos a empezar
tenemos tres lados muy bien así que
vamos a anotarlo en nuestro registro y
ya sabemos por vídeos anteriores cómo
encontrar el área de este triángulo
equilátero el cual es raíz de 3 raíz de
3 por s al cuadrado sobre 4 muy bien
ahora vamos a hacer una división de cada
uno de los lados en tres partes iguales
dividimos en tres partes iguales y
después vamos a tomar el segmento
central del cual vamos a trazar un nuevo
triángulo equilátero va a aparecer de
esta forma si queremos saber cuántos
lados nuevos
vemos en donde había un lado del
triángulo original lo que tenemos que
ver es que tenemos 44 nuevos chequeamos
uno dos tres cuatro lados ok si hacemos
esto a cada paso vamos a tener de cada
lado anterior cuatro nuevos lados ok ya
yo creo que ya puedes ir lo imaginando
vamos a trazar los tres triángulos
nuevos y por lo tanto vamos a tener un
total de tres por cuatro lados que son
dos vamos a contarlos este es 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 12 lados muy bien ahora
cuál es el área bueno vamos a calcular
que es el del triángulo amarillo
original y tres de los nuevos triángulos
que son azules cuál es el área de cada
uno de ellos
eso es tres veces lo que valga su área y
usamos la fórmula que ya conocemos
que es raíz de 3
s al cuadrado en donde ahora ese es un
tercio del lado original que era ese ok
así que ahora éstos tienen longitud s
sobre 3 s sobre 3 todos porque dijimos
que eran equiláteros muy bien
s sobre 3 y ahora esto lo sustituimos
por s sobre 3 al cuadrado sobre todo eso
sobre 4 muy bien vamos a hacer otro paso
vamos a poner triángulos equiláteros de
la misma forma tomamos cada uno de los
lados dividimos entre 3 y nos tomamos el
de enmedio muy bien
ahora cuántos lados tenemos en esta
ocasión bueno lo que vamos a tener es 4
veces 12 lados que teníamos en la
ocasión anterior ok entonces si teníamos
12 basta con multiplicar por 4 que nos
da 48 y van a ser el número de nuevos
lados que obtenemos ahora cuántos nuevos
triángulos hemos obtenido bueno en
realidad lo que queremos sumar ahora es
el área del triángulo amarillo los del
área de los triángulos azules y el área
de los triángulos naranja así que vamos
a tener 12 nuevos 12 nuevos triángulos
naranja ok
pues sí vamos a escribirlo de esta forma
12 y después vamos a tener que
multiplicar por el área de cada uno de
esos que es raíz de 3 por ahora lo que
mide cada uno de los lados de ese
triángulo naranja que en este caso será
ese sobre 9 al cuadrado y eso entre 4
muy bien ahora vamos yo creo que ya
estamos en un buen momento para
determinar cuál es el patrón que vamos a
estar siguiendo ok ya que hemos movido
un poquito la pantalla vamos a cambiar
ahora de colores y hagamos un nuevo paso
ok entonces
el número de triángulos que vamos a
tener es el número de lados que teníamos
en el caso anterior muy bien que lo
multiplicamos por raíz de 3 por lo que
mide ahora el lado que es ese entre 27
al cuadrado sobre 4 muy bien y vamos a
seguir agregando una infinidad de
números para obtener la verdadera área
del copo de nieve de coche así que vamos
a seguir haciendo esto una y otra vez el
el truco realmente es encontrar qué
significa esta suma ok
así que vamos a hacerlo para darnos
cuenta de ello a simplificar esta
expresión ok vamos a escribirlo de una
forma distinta por lo que vamos a
observar primero que podemos factorizar
factorizar un raíz de 3 entre 4 raíz de
3 entre 4 por s cuadrada ok
todo eso lo podemos factorizar de todos
los términos al factorizar el primer
término será un 1 y el segundo
si factor izamos raíz de 3 entre 4 y la
s cuadrada ok y la s cuadrada entonces
sólo vamos a tener 3 por un tercio al
cuadrado que es lo único que nos resta
el único
ok y bueno lo estamos poniendo de esta
forma sin simplificarlo para ver si hay
alguna emergencia de patrones ok ahora
vamos con el siguiente termino vamos a
poner este 12 escrito de la forma 3 por
4 3 por 4 y como ya factor izamos el
raíz de 3 el 4 y la s cuadrada lo único
que nos va a restar es poner un noveno
pero vamos a escribirlo como un tercio
al cuadrado y luego eso lo elevamos al
cuadrado ok
ok ahora ya terminamos con el término
naranja vámonos ahora con el término
rosa ok el 48 vamos a escribirlos como 3
por 4 al cuadrado porque cada vez vamos
a multiplicar por cuatro el término
anterior el coeficiente del término
anterior en cada una de las iteraciones
qué es estar contando el número de lados
de ahí salió ahora ya que hemos factor
izado el raíz de 3 entre 4 por s
cuadrada lo único que nos resta es poner
ahora un tercio al cubo que es 1 entre
27 al cuadrado y así seguimos sumando de
por vida y así seguiremos sumando de por
vida de por vida hasta que acabemos
bueno realmente lo que hacemos en cada
paso es multiplicar por 4 y bueno
podemos pensarlo de esta forma en
realidad estamos sumándole un exponente
cada vez en este primer término es 4 a
la 0 que es 14 a la 1 y 4 al cuadrado
etcétera y por otro lado también estamos
elevando el exponente del un tercio solo
un exponente más en cada término lo que
vamos a hacer es calcular esta suma
infinita como una serie geométrica si
fueran el mismo exponente del 3 y del 4
entonces podríamos hacerlo más fácil así
que vamos a sumar un exponente del todo
4 pero para hacer esto voy a multiplicar
por 4 en cada uno de los términos y al
mismo tiempo para que no se altere la
suma voy a dividir entre 4 muy bien
entonces dividimos entre 4 esto divide
entre 4 a toda la serie después vamos a
multiplicar por 4 toda la suma muy bien
entonces este 1 se vuelve un 4 aquí
multiplicamos por un 4 acá de este lado
se vuelve un 4 al cuadrado aquí 4 al
cubo etcétera
ahora ya tenemos que los cuatros tienen
el mismo exponente que el un tercio el
problema es que el un tercio a la n se
está elevando al cuadrado en todos los
términos pero bueno eso no nos va a
causar problema porque en general si uno
tiene uno entre tres a la n iv luego lo
elevamos al cuadrado esto es lo mismo
que uno entre 3 a la 2 n verdad porque
solo basta con multiplicar los
exponentes
cuando uno está elevando a una potencia
lo que ya tiene elevado a una potencia
así que esto simplemente será 1 entre 3
al cuadrado a la n así que ya tenemos
todas las de la ley para poder
intercambiar nuestros exponentes
ahora vamos a reescribir todo esto y
permítanme que lo haga como raíz de 3
por s
cuadrada entre 16 que multiplica todo lo
de adentro
quiero hacer varios detalles aquí así
que déjenme ponerlo como 4 más
y vamos a escribir 3 por 4 a la 1 en
realidad es haber hecho nada y luego lo
que vamos a hacer es reescribir este
tercio al cuadrado como simplemente 1
entre 3 al cuadrado que es un noveno y
elevándolo todo eso a la primera
potencia solo lo ponemos como un noveno
a la 1 muy bien ahora continuamos con la
parte naranja que es 3 por 4 al cuadrado
por un tercio al cuadrado al cuadrado
que en realidad es un noveno al cuadrado
y ahora terminemos con la parte rosa que
es 3 por 4 al cubo y que multiplica a un
tercio al cubo al cuadrado que en
realidad esto es un 27 ago al cuadrado
pero vamos a utilizar la fórmula que ya
demostramos hace hace unos momentos y
esto es 1 entre 3 al cubo al cuadrado
será lo mismo que 1 entre 3 al cuadrado
al cubo
qué es lo que ya mostramos en esta parte
esto será equivalente entonces a un
noveno al cubo más todos los términos
que dijimos que que nos falta va a ser
muy bien ahora vamos a hacer un paso más
para terminar este vídeo esto será igual
a raíz de tres por s al cuadrado entre
16 que multiplica 4 más y vamos a sumar
3 por 4 novenos más el siguiente término
será 3 por 4 novenos al cuadrado y el
siguiente término lo que vamos a hacer
es multiplicar a tres por cuatro novenos
al cubo y vamos a seguir sumando los
demás términos que nos faltan y si
observamos bien lo que estamos haciendo
es tomar potencias cada vez más grandes
de cuatro novenos lo que haremos en el
siguiente vídeo será recordar todas esas
herramientas que tenemos para calcular
series infinitas geométricas pero ahí
mismo vamos a repasar lo